est ce que ce sont des aliens qui
viennent enfin de chercher on avait un
vidéo club qui est à une demi heure de
chez nous au lavage
[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle les namas foot mais
tout le monde l'appelle l'ena situation
sur internet et j'ai 24 ans
mon premier pseudo c'était ma foufoune
c'est évidemment pas moi qui l'ait
choisi c'était mon nom donc si surnom
collège quand on l'a découverte mon
tennis était mahfouf et ouais
je sais pas je sais que j'ai plus de
deux millions d'abonnés sur youtube mais
je sais pas exactement combien non je
vais regarder 2 millions vous savez moi
je sais pas je devais les avancements
faut des millions 2 121 mille au japon
juge avait passé les deux seconds merci
je voulais être créatrice de mode comme
ma maman quand j'ai découvert que tu
pouvais raconter des histoires avec le
milieu de la mode gt c'est ça que je
veux faire
a complètement là je suis en plein de
temps je vais tout faire minutes et
dernière vidéo tu étais une prochaine
vidéo elle soit mieux que la dernière et
après tu rentres sortes de trucs où tu
te cramant fait et tu perds un peu ce
plaisir les créateurs de contenu il ya
toujours cette sorte de choses
on est comparé les uns avec les autres
et on nous fait croire qu'elle est là
parce que pour une seule personne mais
je pense que quand tu rentres là dedans
ça te bouzy créativement est étudiée
mais lui il a fait ça à lui il avait une
tel produit il a réussi à faire une
vidéo avec 5 cadreur et que ta tête des
choses bêtes mais qui peuvent te cramer
il faut vraiment de serre et à prendre
du recul et est à dire ok je le faire
pour moi maintenant
[Musique]
je sais moi y'a un truc qui m'a beaucoup
aidé c'est que on est plein de créateurs
de contenu et on fait tous le même
métier mais façon très différente on se
retrouve un peu tous les uns les autres
et tu peux parler avec un c'est bon que
je connais bien qui m'a donné beaucoup
beaucoup de conseils mais tu as aussi
des squeeze de mac faye karito sommes
aussi des youtube heures qui sont
spécialisés dans des chaînes ip rni et
au final on a tous plein de sentiments
qui sont hyper commun et c'est assez
rassurant de se dire toi bon plan cette
panne créative où ce burnout ou alors
cette hyper inspiration alors ce méga
plaisir mais il y en a qui sont en train
de vivre de leur côté quand on se
retrouve tous ensemble c'est assez
agréable donc je pense que le vrai
conseil quand madonna s'était juste ne
pas rester seul enfermé là dedans et
d'en parler avec les autres avec les
collègues dans un temps si bien
[Musique]
je sais pas moi ça fait pas longtemps
que je ne viendrais faudrait demander
aux autres mais tu vois par le concept
comme exemple parce que ça fait dix ans
qu'il est sur internet et que des gens
ont grandi avec seb l'afrique il a tout
type de contenu et que un coup tu peux
avoir des challenge vraiment de zozo et
puis tu peux avoir aussi un docu sur la
papouasie puis après tu peux voir des
clips et des fois je le vois il écrit
des vidéos pendant trois semaines donc
en gros lui se fait vraiment vraiment
kiffé sur son contenu et ils ne parlent
de choses que qui l'excitent dont
quelque chose qu'ils excitaient quand il
avait 14 ans ne sont pas les mêmes que
celles d'aujourd'hui et c'est pas pour
autant qu'il est bloqué dans ce qu'il
faisait quand il avait 14 ans donc je
pense sincèrement que le modèle side of
flies est pas mal
évidemment très honoré c'est un festival
très prestigieux c'est quelque chose qui
est hyper important parce que nous tous
qui faisons de la vidéo même si les
plateformes sont différentes et la
pression de créer complètement
différente à la fin de la journée on a
tous cette même envie c'est raconter des
histoires ou au moins de divertir les
gens pendant un instant de leur journée
donc du coup je trouve ça très inspirant
et ça me donne envie de voir aussi
comment eux réfléchissent quand il crie
intime c'est fascinant de voir le nombre
de personnes qui travaillent dessus et
je suis aussi quand même très
au courant que la présence
d'influenceurs sur le festival de cannes
peut être ouvert à débat et je l'entends
et je comprends tout à fait mais je
pense que c'est cool de montrer aux
jeunes qui consomment des contenus
beaucoup plus court est beaucoup plus
dynamique que le cinéma reste quelque
chose d'extrêmement précieux et c'est
super cool et qu'il faut qu'on continue
d'aller au cinéma qu'on
a je pense que c'est le même souvenir
que tous les enfants douze années 2000
c'était le vidéo club nous on avait
envie d'un club qui est à une demi heure
de chez nous donc on y aller en vélo
avec mon père c'était une demi heure de
vélo c'était une négociation avec mon
père c'était une deadline pour regarder
le film donc à danser ça se mérite et
c'est pas juste ouvrir internet je fais
de ces banques est ce que je regardais
ce soir c'est plus compliqué que ça
le film qui m'a le plus marqué d'une
très très grand fan de wes anderson
pense que c'est la première fois que
j'ai vu un film où la photo de choc au
point où to be l'histoire en fait
tellement beau symétrique et réfléchie
c'est très intelligent
[Musique]
tout le milieu du cinéma inspire de ouf
et il me fascine parce que c'est des
années de travail c'est des milliers de
personnes qui se retrouvent sur un
projet commun tout ça pour une heure et
demie de film tu vois et donc du coup
nous on le voit mais sur une échelle
tellement plus petit puisqu'une vidéo 20
minutes déjà sur youtube c'est une
grande vidéo donc du coup tu te dis voit
le travail que c'est la passion des gens
bonjour ça fasse non moi je ne peux pas
attendre un an de montage sont pas
donnés je lève ou quatre ans maintenant
tu vas donc du coup la patience du
cinéma français me fascine et après en
tant que cinéaste wes anderson
[Musique]
déjà je vais vous dire un truc à cannes
une journée équivaut à dix jours à paris
c'est un une ville où il se passe
tellement de choses que ton énergie elle
est aspiré par l'énergie du festival de
cannes que le pouf c'est peut-être la
soirée elvis qui était complètement
folle donc tu arrives dans une plage et
puis d'un coup tu vois des toits dans le
site jiwa ou est ce que ce sont des
aliens qui viennent enfin de chercher et
non en fait ils font des drones qui sont
en train de former la silhouette d'elvis
en train de penser voilà cette phrase
n'existe pas dans un autre contexte que
le festival de cannes
je comprends j'entends
je pense que
buts de du festival de cannes et et
d'inviter des influenceurs ça va être de
mettre en lumière justement tout le
travail que c est faire en sorte que le
cinéma garde cette énergie qu'il a mais
je pense que c'est une bonne façon de
montrer qu'il ya certains et créateurs
de contenu pour qui on ne s'est pas
simplement posté une photo et puis c'est
bon ça s'arrête là je vous promets j'ai
fait des tournages avec des youtube
heure où tu te dis c'est des prod
vraiment de cdd courts métrages c'était
du film c'était la prod de télé donc je
pense que c'est une bonne façon de
mettre de la lumière sur le travail des
créateurs de contenu ceux qui sont là
pour parler de cinéma est également de
mettre de la lumière sur le cinéma parce
qu'on a une audience qui est peut-être
moins familière avec ça puisqu'on a
moins grandi avec avec le cinéma puisque
c'est pas la seule façon qu'on a de voir
un signe
[Musique]
en
haut la vache alors si un biopic sur moi
job à merde c'est pas rihanna je sais
pas si j'accepte ya un biopic sur moi je
pense que vous pouvez utiliser toutes
les images de mes blogs puisque j'ai
déjà tout filmé donc je ne sais pas ce
qui est encore à montrer comment les
atouts entrez donc vous pouvez visiter
les images d'archivés
[Musique]
c'est un mélange de reconnaissance
d'honneur et de gueule de bois
merci brut de m'avoir appelé pour venir
papoter avec vous c'est un plaisir et
j'espère que nous a diverti des bisous y
est allé voir l'interview avec une passe
de norman s'il vous plaît